so the number one thing we need more
than anything to win is hunger which
comes from a state of desperation you
know exactly what you're afraid of you
know exactly what you've been avoiding
and you got to make a decision to change
in you've got to start to build a habit
of being decisive successful people
happy people leaders are decisive people
but the underestimated thing in life is
the ability to communicate your thoughts
and your ideas and the world today
information is a dime a dozen need
motivation watch the top ten with belief
nation
he said my let and here's my take on his
top ten rules of success volume seven
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one be hungry how bad do you want your
goal right now I think there's a lot of
people in the world today because it's a
really nice thing to talk about I want
this this is my outcome this is my goal
like how bad do you want as bad as
breathing do you want it as bad as
anything you've ever wanted in your life
and if you calibrate it at the highest
enough levels where I found the people
that are the hungriest they find a way
when you know why you want something
when it's desperation the power of being
desperate is something that most people
avoid they think desperation is a
weakness and I'm here to tell you
desperation is one of the most powerful
emotions you could possibly possess
because when you're desperate you find
reserves and reservoirs of ideas talents
and a strength that you don't know you
have when you find yourself in a
desperate situation so ironically the
one thing most people avoid in their
life hunger which is caused by being
desperate when you're starving
you become desperate think of somebody
who's starving on the street they've got
to how resourceful would you get if your
children were literally starving and you
had to feed them right so the number one
thing we need more than anything to win
is hunger which comes from a state of
desperation yet we're constantly trying
to comfort ourselves in the real world
to avoid the state of being desperate
and I'm telling you that I think you
need to embrace desperation again in
your life like do you want it so bad
that you're desperate for it see in a
fight you show me to people this is why
it's so hard to repeat as a champion in
the fighting game because you show me
someone who's up-and-coming as hungry
for that title who's never had it before
who can taste it who knows if they win
that belt their whole life's gonna
change they're gonna be champion of the
world all the endorsements all the money
all their family life all their parents
lives are gonna change you show me
somebody chasing that hungry for it
against some of those just trying to
hold on to a title and that's why most
of the time the challenger beats the
champ it's hard to repeat as a champion
because the hunger goes down just a
little bit
the greatest athletes the Kobe's the
Bradys the Jordans of sports have a way
of feeding their hunger all the time and
increasing it what separates them isn't
just their work ethic isn't just their
talent although those things matter
isn't just they practice more what
separates them as they're just hungrier
they somehow find a way as they climb up
the ranks and win championship to get
even hungrier for more where 99% of the
athletes lose just a little bit of their
edge once they get that first
championship that first pro contract
that first big amount of money that
first world championship they just lose
their hunger a little bit and then
there's the elite they get hungrier it
feeds the beast rule number two take
responsibility no one's gonna do
anything for you couple rules of being a
real leader you need to take
responsibility for your own life bring
an energy to your team leading and
recruiting leading in leadership leading
in growth
nobody owes you anything but you owe
other people everything that's what a
leader does you take responsibility you
know exactly right now what you're not
doing it would be criminal of you to
leave here and say I don't know what to
do you know exactly what you're afraid
of
you know exactly what you've been
avoiding and you got to make a decision
to change it you know exactly what it is
don't BS anybody you know what you need
to do different you know the changes you
need to make and if you could do that
and stop kidding yourself you can win
you can overcome your fear overcome
procrastination whatever that is rule
number three change your patterns you
are not your possessions
you are not your accomplishments you are
not what other people say you are you
are not what you look like and guess
what else you're not you are not your
patterns but your life becomes a
combination and a result of your
patterns the great thing about us is
that we can change these patterns if we
identify them the pattern has no power
over you once you know it's a program
and a pattern running the minute you
start you go Mike I'm doing it again
aren't I I'm doing this thing I do every
time I accumulate money I'm doing the
same thing every time me and my spouse
get in a disagreement I'm doing the same
thing every time I'm starting to feel
loved by somebody and I push them away
every
time things start to go bad financially
I spiral every time there's adversity I
do the same pattern where I start
worrying every time I get fit I do the
same pattern when you begin to see these
things you begin to go my gosh this
isn't Who I am
that's not your identity there's a
difference between your identity and
your pattern and the more you begin to
build your identity as I've talked about
my other audios and be aware of patterns
and then simply ask yourself when this
comes up again in the future what
pattern would serve me what pattern can
I take control of what would be the
steps I need to take that will create
the bliss I want or the win I want or
the production I want what would the
pattern need to be rule number four be
decisive you've got to start to build a
habit of being decisive successful
people happy people leaders are decisive
people and I believe somewhere if
there's a hundred problems challenges in
life 85 of them should be decided
immediately with not a lot of
deliberation and then certainty and
massive action will eliminate that
challenge of that problem most of the
time it's the people who procrastinate
on the problem or ignore it or think it
might go away
that gives that problem time to magnify
to fester to grow to where now it's
become bigger than it needed to be also
if you want to learn how to have more
confidence check in my 250 for
confidence series it's free the link is
in the description below the reason
people aren't patient is they value
other people's opinions too much you
have to go build self-confidence so
while you're in this passionate state
that's where you make decisions rule
number five believe lack of belief it'll
steal your dream you got to know you're
gonna win you gotta have some faith
these people sitting around you right
now
they're whispering to you you could do
this I believe it just like when you
were a little boy just like when you
were a little girl
they've always believed in you they've
always known you're gonna do something
special they always knew you were great
you need to know it you need to take
that God that's sitting there with you
and those precious souls that have
passed that have always believed in you
and you carry them with you everywhere
they're with you anyway acknowledge them
if you don't believe that
or them honor God honor these people who
believed in you
with your magnificent life honor them
don't give in to lack of belief lack of
confidence don't ever do that again
don't do it NW fgr out of wfg you were
made to do something great you're
special
you're made the image of God something
awesome supposed to happen for you and
those of you that have made something
that awesome happened something even
more awesome supposed to happen for you
rule number six don't compare yourself
to others don't compare yourself most of
the people you see on social media or
even in your personal life or even when
you go to lunch with them or see them at
work they're wearing what I would call a
public mask it's the best possible
version that they can put out to
themselves and oftentimes what we do in
life is we compare our real identity
that we're working on and we're growing
to their mask and that's not fair to
ourselves at all any comparison doesn't
serve us and it's oftentimes this
comparison when you're in a disagreement
with somebody it's the mask they're
wearing compared to the identity you
have and then you begin to run a pattern
to respond to it
it happens in in Fitness in
relationships in money and in business
remember you're in charge of controlling
your own identity and growing your own
identity and being aware of the patterns
you have that do and do not serve you
not comparing yourself to someone else
as public representative it's just the
representative they're putting out there
it's not who they really are and it's
not something that you need to be aware
of because it's not something you can
control the more you can begin to
delineate in life between things I can
control and I cannot control would be to
the extent that you're more productive
and you're happier you can control your
own thoughts your own emotions your own
identity and your own patterns not other
people's rule number seven get
laser-focused human beings that get
obsessed and immersed in any topic to
become great at it and so can you so
pick what you want and get laser-focused
begin to eliminate all the distractions
you are not hungry enough you are not
starving enough and you are not focused
enough I say this to you as a friend
what are the things that are stealing
your focus who are the people that are
stealing your focus and begin to
eliminate these distractions get laser
focus and obsessed on what you want be
starving and hungry to get it be
desperate to get it the
combination of desperation and hunger
with laser focus over an extended period
of time
is the formula to be great at something
and you can apply this formula get laser
focused eliminate distractions eliminate
the things that steal your laser focused
on it your research on it your obsession
on it begin to do these things and you
will begin to change your entire life
rule number eight master communication
what is uh probably the most important
thing to me in my life is I think that
my children think that their daddy helps
people and what they've learned from me
both of them is massive work ethic both
my kids are super hard-working good
people all I want them to have when they
leave my house is I want them to have my
work ethic and I want them to have their
faith and I want them to have
self-confidence and I want them to be
able to communicate I think if you can
leave the family with those things work
ethic faith self-confidence and the
ability to communicate you're probably
gonna have a pretty good life it takes
care of every area your face gonna make
sure you're a good person and you
contribute and you do well and you've
got morals your self-confidence is
obvious work ethic is obvious but the
underestimated thing in life is the
ability to communicate your thoughts and
your ideas and the world today
information is a dime a dozen if you're
going to succeed in this life you have
to be able to communicate how you're
feeling and thinking and transfer
information to people and I want them to
be good at that too those are the things
I always think of with my kids rule
number nine focus on a solution not a
problem problems need energy to live I
want you to own that remember this
problems need energy to live and so the
concept should be that we solve problems
but we don't have to pour and deplete
ourselves of energy because the more
energy you give something the more it
expands we want to be in the max out
universe we want to pour our energy and
expense our energy towards the solution
not towards the problem so the first
thing I want you to write down is ninety
percent of your energy focus time and
thought should be towards the solution
not towards the problem itself this is a
mistake most people make because they
expend all the energy into the problem
they obsess over the problem the problem
and when
you expand energy it grows to survive
and the problem gets bigger and bigger
and bigger and bigger and the solution
becomes more and more difficult so the
first thing is can you consciously begin
to focus on energy expansion into the
solution 90% of it into the solution and
not into the problem what we do is we
repeat that problem over and over and
over again and we magnify it to the
point where we don't come up with
realistic solutions and we deplete
ourselves as energy towards the solution
and so focus going forward when a
problem arises and a challenge arises
that you focus 90% of your energy and
thoughts on the solution and not
repeating the problem to yourself and
rule number 10 the last one before a
very special bonus clip is seek more
bliss assuming you want more bliss in
your life decide to have it and take
some actions towards getting it so let
me ask you a question
what are you doing currently to create
more bliss in your life what are the
actions you're taking to give yourself
more bliss you were intentionally
seeking more bliss because bliss is
gonna lead to more wealth more abundance
more fitness more faith better
relationships more happiness more peace
more wins
more success more recognition more
significance so what are you consciously
doing now that you've chosen bliss
what is the consistent action you're
taking to create more in your life what
are you doing to give yourself bliss now
I've got a special bonus cut from Ed on
how to compete that I really think
you're gonna enjoy but before that it's
time for the three point landing
question it's time to go from just
watching a video to taking action here
question number one what's the problem
you see people complaining about that
you can solve number two where do you
need to stop comparing yourself to
others and number three what daily
pattern of yours do you need to change
you gotta compete I agree with what
Monty said yesterday you have to be
number one but dadgum it you better want
to compete to be the best version of you
you could possibly be your desire and
will to win is everything I believe you
win with intangibles
with emotion with energy with passion
and you got to bring that
if you want more add my lad check out
the top 50 rules video I made on him the
link is right there next to me I think
you'll enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
the comfortable road will never lead you
to the person you were destined to be
ever in your life I'm constantly in a
crisis to get to the next version of